hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gary dark secrets my name is
markiplier and we're about to bust out
of the cell bust out of the cell I see a
hole no I let me let me let me try
something to get this flashlight cuz I'm
just gonna it's gonna if it's just gonna
be bug the rest of the game I might as
well try to fix it I probably should
I've done that you know when I was in
between recordings but I want you to see
everything I do okay no no no no that's
creepy
that's that sounded really creepy so
okay and now we load forever yeah I said
it on this in the off time but and I
still get put that my fat night the fast
light is broken
damn lit all right whatever I'll just
have to make do Oh to have a flashlight
yet haha
there we are if I'd have waited just two
seconds I wouldn't have had to reload
and waste all that time busting out of
here okie dokie busting back in okay so
much pain shut up you shut up oh hello
you're in there I'll try yeah maybe I
will maybe I will it's really up to me
isn't it you know
what I want as opposed to what you want
yeah
Oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate sing so much I
hate him
I hate them I just having a rat all [ __ ]
you rock god damn it okay we got here ah
oh look a perfect hiding spot
oh yeah [ __ ]
you're not even here are you [ __ ] off
oh you're not even there oh you're right
there oh I'm an idiot
oh I heard the little squeal oh I'm such
an idiot
I'm such an idiot where is he oh you
went away oh I'm an idiot okay what oh
god damn it okay
all right let's go I don't like sitting
around hiding all the monsters I feel
like this boring okay I like sitting
around hiding for the monsters okay it's
gonna come in here and then I run around
why why go see him do you see him I
don't see him see me that's right get
out of here
don't do your squeal music right now I
go by I go by him come on alright fine
you wanna you wanna dance
you wanna dance brother you wanna dance
oh what a gay alright around you so
stupid uh-huh it's so stupid just stupid
that guy's Oh bingo Bongo tears I win oh
yeah chair party in here oh wait why are
you cheers all facing the wall judge try
to break down that door you don't matter
I'm not there just don't ya don't matter
it don't matter buddy like you even
can't get near me oh yeah oh yeah I'm
like low and past everything you
imagined and everything you wish you
were a monster everything you wish you
were Wow man these levels are big I mean
I don't know how long this mod is but so
far it's very impressive
there's a container ah
jump-scare no ok hello cow bull bull
actually not a cow aborted the title
[Music]
okay no it's a monster gone I'm assuming
I'm assuming it's gone okay let's see
what's down here
besides [ __ ] mannequins that's going
to change okay
Georgia yeah getting rid of this rubble
seem to be my only option if I want to
continue okay so I got a container maybe
I could find some sort of explosive
concoction I like that word concoction
it's a good word okay here the Manuel
Romero ah [ __ ] me
oh man
Oh oh come on why are they everywhere Oh
what do I gotta go down here probably
what is that calamine calamine lotion
something done oh god I was gonna get me
it's gonna get me he's gonna get me it's
gonna get me it's gonna get me let's go
get me what is down there Oh Oh
something gonna come out it's gonna get
me oh I don't like that I don't like it
at all
Oh actually what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna because I think there might be
something god damn it Oh [ __ ] hell
I'm actually gonna get a box I'm I go
down and try to jump in it there's
probably stupid if I gonna kill me but
yeah I'm just curious he strike up yeah
yeah go to hell you go to hell and you
die alright because I'm just curious
because you know seems like something's
here okay alright won't even let me oh
okay alright nevermind then that was a
waste of time
how's the big fat waste of time come
here monster come here I just want to I
just want to talk with you I just want
to talk with you all right spike alright
alright so I got the calamine cuz I
didn't know calamine lotion was an
explosive mixture but [ __ ] they're
everywhere [ __ ] hell I'm recording
I'm literally recording right now anyway
well my mom decided to pay me a visit
okay I'm being chase
one second bug out Dubey I didn't go
anyway no and they dropped the dog in
here well that's that basically ruins
all the atmosphere just kill me they'll
be right now my doggie ed my doggie the
devotion the camera boda boda booty what
about you voted oh your booty look at a
camera look at the camera look yogi the
camera is my doggie it's not my dog it's
my mama's Augie my rum okay all right
wow that was weird
now back to the terror I'm kind of not
scared at all anymore so ah that's
unfortunate but whatever what you gonna
do oh well I need you got to see my
puppy oh come on
where am I I don't even know where I am
anymore ah [ __ ] you you wanna you want
to dance again oh that's right you don't
like a chair Oh what's up what's up walk
out chair did nothing
how about a barrel I swear the chairs
like recently it's been doing less and
less I swear when I started out the
chair did tremendous damage like amazing
dabbling you miss me right there when I
turned around our this devolved in this
silliness
all right back into serious mode
okay no let's try this again so now I
imagine the monster is gonna come up
right about here or have I spawned all
the monsters that are gonna spawn and no
no more will spawn all right whatever it
doesn't matter I'm wheeling this way I
went down there that's why I picked up
the calamine this is where I jumped in
for the moment and this is where my mom
interrupted me for the moment and I went
in others worried this is where I came
out of that's the jail cells so I gotta
find something else down ah here we go
up this snow that ladder leads nowhere I
was a library it's a library ladder
books oh oh oh oh don't make me go down
there oh [ __ ] you okay down here looks
good
better than the dark blood-red room I'm
just assuming okay line man this is
convoluted it's seriously don't all over
the place Oh what's this ah how about a
hammer
I remember this poison gland I probably
got to find a lab to actually mix it
like before it's actually in in similar
location of the original amnesia there
was a torture chambers and you're trying
to find this stuff you were trying to
find the pieces of the orb actually man
it seems like forever since I played
amnesia like man I mean the original
image I've been playing amnesia ever
since but the original amnesia that was
good hi buddy how you doing another one
oh [ __ ] me I'm so boned oh let me at
least read this note
explosive reminder dammit
that's the third came in this week and
this one time one of the servants was
crushed by the rubble damn thing wasn't
able to make it out of the blast zone
no matter they're easily replaced what
is actually proving to be a problem is
that I am more and more often finding my
route to the mansion blocked by caved in
passages as a result I have determined a
formula for a particularly potent
explosive that can be easily sourced
easily resource by nearby ingredients
I'm recording the process here for the
fuse
one combiner adequate amounts of aqua
regia and calamine into a chemistry
container must be suitably heated over a
burner before further use combined the
filtered contents of the poisonous plant
which will be automatically extracted by
placing the whole plant into the
extractor place the heated aqua regia
and calamine mixture at the proper end
of the machine close the door or the
never if done properly this will result
in a highly potent explosive that should
be handled with extreme care remember to
retreat a safe distance after placing
the explosive don't want to end up like
the last servant to handle the stuff
okay I'm boned
I am boned hi buddy you're hitting your
own guy there okay I'm gonna just crouch
down act like you're not there and
you'll go away right I'll put this in
front of me so that you can't see me oh
it's going around expect that okay all
right man there are so many monsters on
this level I don't know if like oh man
it's like ridiculous how many monsters
there okay I just need to find aqua
arisia
but actually that's gonna have to wait
until the next episode because I am all
out of time Wow look the chains are
moving I never noticed that before
anyway thank you all so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this episode
of kind of silliness and scares I think
that's what I'll name is silliness and
scares anyway thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye